yeah to end welcome to this video in
Navarro in Navarro
it's my opponent it's go for the
Delphian Carol I'm black now we'll
commit in some way okay yeah this is not
so bad I mean it doesn't look yeah like
the first thing that comes to mind let's
say move the pawns but it is playable I
could have played before as well and
maybe this is better and let's go before
it's interesting now he's got a 5 but I
mean the a pawn is a liability so what
is he doing there c6 I'm going to stop
the pawn let's do that so that Knight c3
can be played to just a tacit it's not
so easy to give additional cover to the
pawn I mean you definitely don't want to
play b5 at some point and in most cases
it won't be even possible Bishop c5 what
is the bishop doing on the f1 at five
okay so it's not really worried about
the pawn
maybe okay he just gives me the pawn
I'll take it
maybe there was no way to save it hmm
new night to be six is the simple threat
and how to do this down or maybe e-form
get additional grip in the center
yeah I have c5 I think I'm going to play
it I think it should be right if I can
trade D against Suppan he will have some
issues with the pawn on e5
so here and yeah it doesn't really have
a very satisfactory move now
yeah this is one of the better better
ones but I'm quite happy here
just get the knight back into the game
and this is interesting because you can
argue that night b1 is correct get it to
C form quickly yeah I think this is
right you know in this f5 is kind of fun
f5 is ridiculous really if you would
play that probably you will play it
because yeah other moves look terrible
as well but it will only weaken his
position and doesn't really help
now I can't even go G for now and win a
piece
give it me the piece some check first
okay let's take this first and now even
Knight f7 is possible now but it's the
case where I'm basically everything wins
this is good though those two g7 I go
Knight g5 the 96's is terrible really
it's a fork on three pieces Queen rook
King well it's wrong value yeah press
this button yeah that was bit a bit of a
disaster but I don't know he simply
didn't care about the opening result it
felt a 5 is I think this is play well if
you want to do it it is some more I
think advisable to do it like that
provoked you for first and then go away
5 but it's just what setup is quite slow
so you can do things like a5 a4 without
being immediately and yeah punished
I think he should take now and not allow
me to play before because this pawn will
become a liability but now he - the next
moves out very quickly not really yeah I
don't know
looking for something good this Bishop
at 5:27 I mean it's pretty clear that I
want to win the a pawn and he just never
did anything against it so this is just
lost basically before age 5 I think c5
is a strategically good move
making him while trying to trade C
against D pawn ultimately I decided to
get get here Knight b6 ok but this is ok
get denied back into the game and here I
think this is slow but the knight should
be on c4 so 91 and as I mentioned this
is f5 business is basically suicide
but I understand that he wanted to do
something if I just get all the time in
the world I would win automatically this
is just just a disaster I win the house
yeah I don't know him
maybe he thought that my opening is
entirely harmless so you can let you can
play anything but it's not weakening
yourself and then just dropping material
and doesn't doesn't do the trick even
against the snow opening okay guys
thanks for watching